hello and welcome to GameSpot's play for
all we are covering so many of the
latest and greatest games and we have a
special segment here today because we're
talking about Borderlands threes dlc 3
which is called bounty of blood and I'm
joined by Matt Cox the creative director
for the DLC how you doing Matt I'm doing
great how are you doing I'm hanging in
there so a lot of many Borderlands fans
probably got a peek of bounty blood by
the Borderlands show or maybe some of
the gameplay videos there's some
information out there but for those who
may not be caught up with what this DLC
offers can you give sort of a foundation
for what bounty of blood is offering
absolutely bounty of blood is a story of
revenge the vault hunters arrive on a
brutal frontier planet called Gehenna in
the hopes of collecting the sheriff's
bounty on this gang known as the devil
riders now the devil riders are a very
violent gang of Beast riding mercenaries
and you're gonna team up with the locals
to save the town of vestage now the
vault hunter is gonna take the fight
straight to the devil riders using new
gameplay objects that we've added to
bounty of blood also including a new jet
beast vehicle in a tale that is told by
an unseen narrator yes so I think the
first thing I want to get out of the way
it's talking about the jet beasts
because that's the first thing that's
death to me in the in the gameplay
videos I think is the first time you've
added vehicles since or a vehicle since
the base game if I recall correctly but
yeah tell me about you Jeff like the
gymnast is kind of a half jet bike half
creature really it's like a like you
have the dinosaur likes Orion head
mounted on the front of basically a
hover jet bike and to me very early on
when we were trying to figure out like
when we're making a Western Focus DLC
it's like how you can't have a Western
without a horse right and so we decided
for the players it's going to be
something cooler than a horse it'll have
to be a hover bike with some cool
weaponry and different heads that you
can mount on on the front and so when
you're riding in the frontier it's
called the blast plains our big zone map
is called the blast plains you get to do
some really cool jet beast combat
personally I'm
fan of vehicle combat and we love the
borderlands loop the borderlands loop a
combat loop is tried and tested not only
do you had did you player get to use the
jet beast in all these cool weapons but
the devil riders are riding experimented
on saurians so they're literally on the
backs of creatures fighting while you
have this amazing jet beast so there is
a much more focused vehicle combat
dynamic as you're trying to travel from
point A to point B just getting to the
new mission or a new side mission as
you're traveling through the the blast
plains and part of that is plays into
poor Lanza's style of humour now some
folks may have certain feelings about
the way borderlands has used humor
throughout its history but for this dlc
i know that it's a story about revenge
and it has a narrator and there so it
almost gives off this vibe of something
that's a little bit more serious but how
do you one channel in Borderlands style
of humor but also how do you keep that
fresh if that's what you're trying to do
man I feel like you are actually in on
some of our earlier conversations when
we were trying to know what this dlc is
because that's that's actually a
conversation that we had very early on
we did want to take with the main plot a
little bit more of a serious tone a
little more measured tone quieter may
not be the right word because we do have
a narrator that is constant that does
talk about what we are doing and gives
more flavor to the story without actual
character dialogue having to happen now
that being said we have a lot of new
characters in this DLC and a very it's a
simple story overall like it is a
revenge like seek revenge on the devil
riders but having that focused of a plot
allows the characters that we build
around it a lot more room to breathe and
us to get attached to them so yeah what
you said is very much true we did try to
get a little bit more of a serious tone
with the main story of bounty of blood
but it's Borderlands so we're we still
look for all of those opportunities to
for the traditional Borderlands humor
then you'll see a lot more of that in
the side missions but on the main plot I
people are in for something pretty
unique and fresh the borderlines you
mentioned earlier that you know you and
the team are very focused on this DLC a
lot of things that happen around the
edges for Borderlands 3 is kind of not
really what you're you're you're focused
on because you're trying to work on the
DLC so how much creative freedom do you
have in kind of making this your own
sort of thing while also accounting for
how Borland's 3 has been shifting
through its lifespan DLCs are one of our
favorite places gearbox to experiment
and push boundaries of what people
expect from Borderlands not so much
where you can't recognize that it's a
Borderlands game of course you still
have the slew loop right but you know it
we do have we do have some freedom to
try some new things we with certain
story moments and we're keeping a lot of
the story close to the chest because we
built something we think is pretty
special some surprises here and there
and I just want to say this when I say
surprises I know a lot of people think
up returning characters are coming back
who is it
but I just want to be very clear that
the only returning characters are the
vault hunters themselves the planet of
Gehenna and all the characters Reap we
meet are all all brand new but we were
able to do experiment on some new types
of spectacles and stuff that maybe we
haven't had the chance to do in
Borderlands in a very long time that's
funny you mentioned that because my next
question they actually have on my notes
doc right here is talking about how Mad
Max is heist and both love guns and
tacticals kind of reincorporated some
older Borderlands characters but now you
have a like you said the only returning
characters are actually the vault
hunters what kind of like does that
present any like different types of
challenges because I mean not to say
that previous DLCs didn't didn't like
put in the work for that but I think
that you know it's it's an easy way for
character for players to be like oh yes
like yeah I remember that thing and I'm
attached to that but now you're kind of
working with a clean slate that must be
much harder I assume I think yeah there
there's definitely an extra challenge
when you can
assume that the player already has built
an emotion on previous characters coming
right into a new DLC so we definitely
recognize that as a challenge but
another thing that I think is an amazing
strength of the borderlands universe is
that you do have DLCs in previous
Borderlands that did introduce brand new
characters that are now beloved so we
wanted to make sure that the characters
that we introduced are built in a way
that people can get attached to them in
that short span of time of a DLC
campaign right since we don't have the
luxury of counting on people's emotional
attachment to previous characters now
and we recognize that people love that
some of our DLCs do bring back returning
characters but there is a part of the
community that looks for a fresh story
as well and so I think I'm very proud of
our entire team and how we came together
to build new characters around the
bounty of blood plot cool yeah and
Gehenna is gonna be an all new place a
new planet yeah and that you had kind of
have to build out as well but one thing
that's tiny is the town of vestige and I
think there's I've been talking with
some folks and this seems like maybe
your actions are gonna have consequences
that are reflected in vestige can you
dig a little bit more into that yeah
absolutely we wanted the player to feel
not only like when you beat the story
it's like ah I beat the game right but
you wanna we wanted to build some subtle
and maybe sometimes not so subtle
changes in the town that happened
because of the actions that the player
has taken during during the their
missions so if you there's a prisoner
that you can free and if you free the
prisoner comes back to the saloon and
starts singing a song about the main
plot essentially so all the actions that
the player takes you go back to the
saloon and he's updated his song
basically singing about what you did so
it's kind of like it's kind of like
previously on bounty of blood but right
I that's straight up but you go and
listen to his songs like wait a minute I
just did that he's singing about me and
then there are N
PCs that you could meet in some side
missions and you can make a specific
choice in that side mission come back to
town and they will be doing one thing if
you chose a let's say and they'll be
doing another thing if you chose B so if
you complete the entirety of bounty of
blood story mission side missions and
challenges and you go back to the town
of vestige you will be able to not just
subtly perceive but see the results of
your actions
this being Borderlands the core loop of
being a Schluter as they say is all
about the looting and the shooting so
with bounty of blood you know
Borderlands 3 kind of nailed that loop
almost in a way that it makes you look
at and be like if it's not broke don't
fix it but you still want to offer
something new as opposed to what
previous DLC and what the base game did
so with bounty of blood how are you kind
of shifting around or rethinking combat
encounters while enemy types and the
locations like the combat arenas that
you find them in some of the mechanics
of weapons can you tell me a little bit
back that whole mix of things to make
makes a little more fresh yeah you said
it we're very proud of Borderlands a
time-tested loop and we love our gunplay
and we love our core loop and we made a
lot of additions to that and just the
main game in Borderlands 3 with you know
sliding and mantling and all that stuff
but I think our approach for bounty of
blood with these new gameplay objects we
added four new objects to the mix so
just think of them as additive
ingredients to the already strong combat
loop so there's something called a
trader weed where if you shoot it it
releases these bugs that turn enemies to
your side for you know eight eight to
nine seconds so you can basically turn
enemies to your side for a time there is
a core splode ER and core is this
mineral that everybody on Gehenna is
that's what they're mining for is the
the literal core element and a coarse
floater if you melee it it will shotgun
out high damage shrapnel there's also a
Breezer which acts sort of like a jump
pad
but it soars you into the air by a puff
of air and then there is a Tellez a purr
which is essentially a teleporter being
able to travel you let's the player
Trump from point A to point B
instantaneously so we wanted to take
four objects gameplay objects and throw
them into combat mix so while we still
had that core loop going on we have
different avenues of different styles of
combat and ways to negotiate all the
craziness in borderlands cool yeah I
know that it's probably gonna be a ton
of more loot which is core to
borderlands of course can you tell me
about any special legendary weapons
legendary guns that we should be excited
about so there there is a a side mission
where you get to meet soapy Steve and if
you complete that side mission you will
get something called the bubble blaster
that shoots wait for it high damage soap
bubbles I mean who doesn't want that in
in a Borderlands game yeah but there
there are more traditional
legendaries that you can find as well
there's a torque that also has gyro Jets
on sticky bombs that all stick to
enemies as they pass through this wave
so there's a lot there are a lot in
there that say I'm excited for people to
discover and and try out so I think this
is my last deep question I have a few
short ones before we close this out but
in terms of you know Borderlands 3 or
Borderlands in general has had like this
this kind of this history of
incorporating DLC packs in a very
natural way it gets like its player base
excited coming back for more but over
the past few years we've seen games move
to more service style types of games or
its continually updated every few months
or every month there is a new content
new patches but it seems like
Borderlands has a little mix of both but
leaning into that traditional style DLC
how do you and the team kind of account
for the changing of this the way games
are live games and ongoing games are
served to its players yeah I know a lot
of our design team at the outset
of Borderlands 3 you know we're looking
at what all the trends are as well but I
think at the end of the day we wanted to
stay true to what we knew the
borderlands loop is and although you
know with our events and takedowns like
we chose to go with the traditional
story campaign add-ons because I think
for right now that really sits in with
where community is that and the types of
game games that we actually want to make
so yeah you do see some influence there
but I think of it at the very end of the
day our Borderlands DLC is very much us
very much water lance cool alright so
how our players going to be able to
access bounty of blood content do they
have to make to be on the games they're
special like level boosts to get you
right there how's it gonna work for
those who may not be that far into the
base game yeah if you are not as far as
a sanctuary I guess that might be a
spoiler for people who aren't sanctuary
3 you will be able to start a brand new
character at the level to access any
DLCs so DLC one - and bounty of blood
you'll be able to start those DLCs
immediately by creating a new character
that is at DLC level III I'll just say
like going back to our characters I'm
very excited for people to meet rose and
Juno rose and Juno are our two main
characters that anchor this entire story
Rose is our guide and our ally she's the
the first person that we meet who helps
us learn the brutal ways and and helps
us do some combat before he reached the
town of vestage and her family has been
on the planet for generations and then
eventually we'll meet Juneau who is a
rough-and-tumble brawler she has a very
checkered past and the town doesn't
trust her at all and so we get to follow
her story of redemption as well as she
helps us take down the devil riders to
try to earn back that respect from the
town of message so I think that's that's
probably the one of the biggest things I
want to get across
we're excited for people to to meet rose
and Juno oh and also man our audio team
did an amazing job with a very original
soundtrack we we talked about pushing
the boundaries of you know what types of
combat and gameplay things you can do
but we can't leave out what our audio
team did and the soundtrack for bounty
of what is something I mean I'm
definitely looking forward to those are
those are two things that I love a lot
about the games that I love is you know
character development and a bang and
soundtrack so that is music to my ears
man
so yeah Mac Hawks creative director for
a bounty of blood the third DLC pack for
order lands 3 thank you so much for
joining me man hey thanks for having me
out appreciate it of course and all you
find folks out there thank you for
tuning in giving us your attention we
are also doing play for all to raise
funds for a couple different causes
black lives matter and Direct Relief for
Copa 19 relief you can check description
links below of this video and yeah thank
you for watching we have so much more
content coming up and I want you to
stick around and we'll see you there
[Music]
you
[Music]